once a year blitz bits yeah i played in
this at some point i think
let me actually google so i just found
i found my 2019 blitz arena i played
two and a half hours oh i actually
played this person recently this person
beat me in
bullet recently i'm curious like
from last year oh john john davis last
year
happy birthday eric oh thanks so much oh
i played the 2018
yearly blitz as well look at this
this is 2018. anyway let's um
let's focus on the present rather than
the past
so this is a 2020 yearly blitz arena
let's play a game
thanks to everyone who's subbing and
resubbing and cheering
checkmate to reach 1900 on liches
yesterday
thanks for the great con congratulations
i'll play e4 this game
that's great to hear
that's why the g5 emote exists
let's play uh i'll play a scotch
or maybe i'll play a nagmanson
i don't know each six i can take
opponent was scared of this but um yeah
this is pleasant for whites
so my central control i think you rook
move
rookie move something for a month or no
two months good luck
and phyla 2000 solving with prime
and future matthew is a new sub
but subbing in the present or slightly
in the past
thanks everyone and thank you tomonom
sobbing for 11 months almost one year
okay so i'm threatening to take and
uh win a piece
if here then i can move here attacking
the queen and the
pawn okay black
black move the queen but that didn't
really solve the threat
oh i forgot i could berserk maybe i'll
berserk
i'll just berserk low-rated opponents
hmm let's control both files
and thank you umilard yeah welcome
everyone
um when i play the games i won't be
looking at the chat too much
at least when things get complicated
whoa it's three subs in a row
going to go mad ooh this little this is
a fork knight
all the subs have the fortnight emotes
so now i'm up a rook
um let's make a loop for the king
maybe i'll get some i'll get some g5 in
maybe
i am thinking of making my own i am
rosen t-shirt oh
me too me too
actually i have a secret merch store
that
i should start i probably should add
some more products
and then start promoting
because i made oh no my rook
[Music]
i turned the banana thumbnail into a
banana poster
okay that was a nice start
hey top thousand out of
over 3 400 players
thanks so much um so going to go mad
something for one year
mr turtle subbing with prime the real
easy peasy
subbing for 10 months hike time yeah
hype time
playing monsieur canard
from belgium oh i was in belgium
at some point in time eric
i missed you the last couple times you
streamed
are you back to the nomad life uh
not really i so i posted a video a few
days ago
m rosen let's go underscore hfm rose and
let's go underscoring jeff
let's go many times go underscore hfm
rose and let's go underscore hfm rose
and let's go underscore hf
it's it's stafford gamma time let's go
does opponent know what to do
more and more people are knowing what to
do but
it seems like my opponent isn't prepared
or
maybe just perplexed h3 is a good move
hi eric
catching you live after a while oh good
catch
thanks for subbing on
dim something something that's a long
name i don't want to butcher it
but i appreciate your sub yeah good to
see everyone everyone's playing a solid
line
um against this i just go for kind of
a decent piece setup and then
maybe i'll try and be tricky later i
definitely want to castle queen side at
some point maybe go for h5
or h4 rook h5 is one idea
um let's go
let's go queen d6
oh lick tom for the win did i get your
tea
oh maybe i did wait let's see
someone sent me tea um yeah i forgot to
show this someone sent me
tea i've yet to open it it's still in
its original plastic wrapping
but what was it was it like who sent it
thanks so much it looks really
really interesting really intense
it says intense and smoky black tea
which i've never heard of this before um
there's been a
lot of people sending me tea which i do
appreciate it
okay so i'm setting up a trick if
if white tries to save the king then
white loses a queen
i'm still down the pawn i have the
bishop hair and actually because white
gave away the dark skirt bishop
these dark squares are a lot weaker now
and the knight is kind of pinned to this
pawn
we might see f5 f5 i could throw in
bishop e3
or just move back or sack a piece
i have a nice time advantage
that's the thing about the stafford
gambit is
like even if you get maybe a slightly
worse position or objectively worse
position
you can still maybe get a time advantage
oh bitcoin boy hype level five whoa i
wasn't i wasn't paying attention
i think bitcoin boy uh put it over
with the bitcoin bits so much hype
thanks everyone
completing a level five hype train
that's not easy to do
thanks so much everyone and it doesn't
stop king king of late breaks gifting
another sub
to bite jazz and didn't like jazz gift a
sub
to someone earlier maybe and where is my
mate something with pride
eric just came here from youtube been
following you for over a year love your
content
oh that's nice to hear sounds very nice
to hear welcome to twitch
good to have you oh okay g3
g3 is playable it's kind of a sign that
white doesn't know what to do
i'm gonna keep applying pressure if g4 i
have bishop e3 attacking two things
is queen h2 defending
and then maybe queen b6 attacking
okay here i can take okay i won back the
pawn i'm controlling both
castle destination squares so the king
is kind of stuck
it's kind of the wooden shield right
with the queen and the bishop
uh i might as well throw in this check
an a4 for good measure
thanks thanks for the for fun bits
i'll try and have fun with those oh
thank you lord francesco
gifting two subs to welcome back
christopher
my t mine is a citrus hibiscus lol
oh i didn't get that one yet
oh i'll check my mailbox though usually
it notifies me
when when tea or other packages arrive
okay just being solid everything is
actually really nice and stable
i feel like an architect with this
structure
like everything's defended nice
foundation
[Music]
just have to keep building
i'll play queen b6 just the idea of
pushing the pawn because the d-pawn is
pinned
i don't think i'm too afraid of the
f-file it's a nice combination of
pawn bishop
put the bishop on d4
and now go for c4 oh thanks so much
jame jamery something something
something with prime
oh white's king
how to finish things off i'll put the
bishop back and then probably enter g3
and this is very much a feel-good
position oh the other rook is hanging
too
forgot about that buddha bits
i could go for a budapest at some point
let's defend the pawn
it's tricky because rook c6 is coming
you have to be a little bit careful here
rook c6 i have king d7 this pawn is also
weak
oh there's a funny line um yeah if the
king moves here or here i play this when
i win the rook
so that's probably a better try i have
this move
light's pinned and attacked
there's this in this or that
oh my g pawn is passed
okay that was a nice game a nice example
of how to play
kind of um a slightly annoying line
white didn't give me knight g4 i just
had to develop
and wait for some opportunity
easy wins all day
it'll get more difficult i think oh
thanks for the budapest gambit
bits king king of late breaks
i'll try and get in a buddha past
oh but i can't do it when i'm white but
i have an idea
if d-o never mind doesn't say d5 i was
gonna play the
the tennyson gambit so i'll play one of
these
oh opponent may be playing a hippo
this looks very hippo like
do i mess with the hippo let's start
messing with the hippo
okay i want to defend the structure okay
we'll go for h5
one of the best ways to crack the hippo
like when the point of double feeding
cattle is early
is to just use the the uh the rook pawns
um ooh h6 forcing the bishop to go back
where it came from
and then bishop g5 pinning the knight
the queen's tied down to defending the
knight
because the bishop's no longer on g7 and
e5 is coming
oh but e5 came for the wrong color
time to calculate i think i can i can
take
i can take twice and then play f4
and then the queen is going to be tied
down to the knight if here i fork
and if queen goes back i still attack
i think i'm winning a piece in that line
f4 is nice attacking and defending
and yeah this knight is very problematic
okay here i can take
yeah things are are covered the queen's
actually pinned
to the king eric rosen the hippo slayer
watch this ruthless hunter slay one of
chess most ferocious speeds
yeah no fear no problem
don't mess with a hippo slayer
so i can move my king and check
then k7 max volume
alexa play hall of the mountain king max
volume
here's pier gint in the hall of the
mountain king from scoop
by london philharmonic orchestra and
david perry on amazon music i haven't
heard of this one before
is this move but then this move
actually do i want to get copyrighted
probably not alexa stop
it people can open a new tab if they
want to play that song
sorry people i don't want to get
uh demonetized by
a future youtube algorithm
uh let's take
so the weakness in this position is h7
which i'm guaranteed now to win
i could take check promote
but i might as well save the business
monetize my stream
no alexa don't do it
don't do it
i like how when you say that you're
you're the one monetizing the stream
oh my favorite chess stream i love how
you play and calculate
i love how you sub and cheer is this
force mate
this can't be stopped oh it can it can
be delayed by one move
okay this was nice i didn't even have to
to promote wait
in the hall of the mountain is public
domain oh i didn't realize that
paul of the mountain king
hall of the mountain king is public
domain eric but i respect your decision
i still love
you oh alexa play
hall of the mountain king
here's pier gint
okay we're gonna get some nice public
domain
music so i won't get demonetized
hopefully alexa louder
oh this song i i've heard of this one
yeah alexa louder
okay playing vittelf thanks for subbing
river merrell something at tier one
oh it starts off quiet oh is it gonna
get loud uh-oh
someone wanted me to play budapest ooh i
can't play budapest
you play this move nah let's play
symmetrically london maybe
we have a timid variation
oh maybe it'll still be flagged i could
always edit the video
if it is or replace it with a different
[Music]
soundtrack
i do have neighbors but
hopefully it doesn't carry through the
walls too much
let's develop
[Music]
okay let's keep developing
the things have to get exciting soon to
keep pace with the music
but i don't know if it's going to happen
i'll just have to create excitement
somehow
i want to play this and then this yeah
i just want to go for a quick attack
whoa this got really loud really quickly
played faster but my phone's not playing
fast enough
alexa quieter
okay i wanna i wanna attack a knight and
win maybe
if this this this this this this
eventually this
[Music]
is that an airplane oh that's an
airplane i was like wondering what the
it's to pay copyright fines oh
i don't know if that's how it works at
least with youtube
um but thanks for that
i was wondering why there was like an
airplane sound in the song but it wasn't
part of the song it was just an airplane
flying overhead
music bits yeah
now i have to deliver on some dramatic
chess
somehow so i've chased most of the
pieces away from the king side
but now what to do
let's start attacking
i feel like i should play the song when
we're like entering some
some time scramble
i could also play it ah
so i can play it here
i can play it on youtube and then i'll
have full control
because sometimes alexa likes to rebel
hey it's corbla what's up corbla you've
been missed too
i played this move this is a fancy move
i think i can do it though if takes i
take here and then both minor pieces are
hanging
oh knight a5 95 i kind of forgot about
okay let's defend i'm going to lose a
pawn
sadly but i might mate
happily
so it looks like the song is two and a
half minutes
which means i have to time it correctly
okay yeah there goes my pawn
but the attack the attack is going to be
very ferocious also shout out to corbla
thanks for being here people should
check out corella on twitch
celebrity in the chess world and the the
game show world
okay well the opponents see it
opponent saw it so i'm down the pawn but
there's
there's some nice compensation light
squares are very weak and this bishop
isn't really
in a place to defend the light squares
oh i have this move too i probably
should have played h4
sooner rather than later
that should be okay though
yeah i know the tournament starts hey
it's a dollar
from canon jf has no idea what to do
after the opening oh
thankfully oh actually
i was gonna say thankfully most games
aren't determined in the opening
but that's yeah that's why you should
have some idea of what to do after the
opening
uh that's a good move
i should probably take and keep some
attacking potential
i'll go for h4 soon
whoa it's akd7 youtube videos
oh my pleasure i've been trying to keep
up with uploads
there's been some days where like i'm
it's just it's too much
um but
but yeah there is a recent video i
posted about five hours ago
six hours ago
maybe there will be some youtube comment
content from from the stream as well
appreciate that akd707
okay is the volume okay
i think it's okay okay
hopefully now the music will match up to
the game
oh what to do i'm not quite mating yet
or am i don't really want to trade
queens
let's move back
okay eventually i want to play this
no this move yeah
it's so close to meat
but not quite
[Music]
i just want to take my rook
but that's not legal i could flag white
too
so many options oh you know what i could
do take the bishop
and then checkmate
opponent realizes their doom
what to do for white
okay
okay that was the climax of the game
really have to get the timing down oh
was it too loud i'm so sorry if it was
too loud
i hope i didn't destroy too many
people's ears
anyway okay i played four games so far
four out of four yeah i'll just
adjust the volume for the future hello
to
ested 1759 wish me luck eric
first of all i'm going to an actual
chess club oh good luck
be careful of the competition
and of
germs i guess talk
politics bits i don't talk politics on
on stream
i could talk about chess though which is
basically like virtual politics
three oh thanks for the three bits or
the love bits ooh
this is one of the most common traps in
the stafford
yeah let's uh let's go into this
thanks people for the various types of
bits
i'll play queen g5 so i was watching one
of hikaru's
like garbage speed runs and he actually
fell into this trap
as white like this knight g4 line
against a complete beginner too
he still won but it was funny
there should be two decent move
uh let's throw in a check why not
i was actually thinking about doing
doing a youtube video like recapping
that game
uh hikaru falling into this trap then
hikaru fell into another stafford gambit
trap too
so i probably have two youtube videos to
make
um i forgot to answer the question there
is a question about what to do after the
opening
yeah the one dollar donation question oh
opponent wants to fake castle
i could play queen h2 and crush some
dreams
let's play queen h2
some weird stuff happening
i feel like uh a house intruder
is chasing me away it's gonna play here
and offer a draw
or it's a virtual draw offer okay let's
defend the f pawn castle
maybe someday g5
i like surviving the opening but it was
a success i won back the pawn
uh oh but the bishop's being chased away
i could play this and this do you still
give lectures at the st
louis chess club the last video on their
channel was dated in 2019
oh die oh oh pending
as a was a nice gift from white
um yeah i have not taught at st louis
chestnut in a while
so i did give a lecture on one of their
broadcasts
back in march was it march
yeah i was doing candidates i was
working
uh at the chess club as a candidate's
journalist so i was writing all the
daily reports
for uschesschamps.com
um i was back right around the lockdowns
taking place
i'm addicted to a game and that's where
i pre-move as many moves in the
london as possible on move one each time
i remove more and more and hope
my opponent doesn't do well the first
thing
crazy and eat my f4 bishop oh yeah
hopefully
don't don't let them eat your bishop
man you have a calm personality
the first step to overcoming addiction
is to admit it
and to share it with the world i guess
oh thanks for the calm personality bits
okay we have a london opening this is
actually a very pleasant
london structure
do you plan to stream for the next five
hours
oh in the next five oh oh that's how
long the tournament lasts
uh i don't know i might get tired at
some point
but for now i have energy i have coffee
iced coffee
[Music]
chameleon what does chameleon mean
[Music]
not sponsored but delicious
and caffeinated
yeah no tea i was gonna make tea
actually made tea earlier today but i
felt like i needed more of a boost
thanks for subbing firm stripe
solving for two months appreciate that i
still need to ask or to answer this
question from earlier
i keep getting distracted uh the the one
dollar donation question
oh oh yeah there's there's there's a few
questions to address
because i know the um the st louis rapid
and blitz starts really soon
which i was kind of conflicted whether
to
like cover that but there's a bunch of
other channels covering it
and this only happens once a year but so
does that tournament i guess
it's very conflicting
let's try and answer this this question
i have no idea what to do after my
opening
not sure how to set up a good pawn
structure but i still
love watching your stream yeah unlike
unlike the opening middle game is
sometimes
a bit more uh
chaotic in terms of like what you should
be pursuing
like there's like in the opening of
course there's the principles like
control the center develop the pieces
get the king safe
in the middle game it's about trying to
accumulate
different types of advantages fighting
for control over key squares
formulating plans and every position is
different
um so like the best way to improve your
middle game is to like get as much
experience as possible
i look at the games of high level
players
um hopefully i can shed some light in
what to do in this middle game
like everything's defended this is
actually already a nice structure
black might want to play e5
um the e5 isn't too scary
so i mean at a lower level
in the middle game you usually want to
first of all okay minimize blunders keep
things defended
but then try and exploit uh your
opponent's weaknesses
try and set up tactics this position i'm
trying to exploit the weakness on oh
let's say night here attacking the
undefended pawn
um so with this move black actually
creates another weakness
skype always crashes on me oh
i've i used to use skype a lot more just
for general calls
but i've been recently transitioning to
zoom
i'm not really um
i'm not doing as many like private
lessons these days
just because i'm putting more focus into
into streaming and youtube content
but uh i will say i like these days i
probably prefer zoom over skype
okay so i played this to like slow down
any counter play in the center
and the plan is to just double up and
exploit this weak pawn
if i double up i'll also be pinning
this pawn to the rook and maybe i can
win this pawn
so life is good oh thanks for subbing
ragnaros
it counts as a no comments comment
so yes
okay let's move back
if uh yeah if knight be it i can take on
b5
so i'm like with this move i'm
threatening this pawn and this pawn
not easy it's admiral welcome back
thanks so much did i predict your
response correctly
kind of you i don't know if
predicting is the right word you you fed
me my response
i like to be fed responses it's very
delicious
um oh no my pawn
so this actually i might be winning more
stuff
because i can take and take here and
then pin
and then if this i could try and pin
some more
okay that was a nice game that was a
nice kind of london positional grind
if we just go back and reflect
um
yeah so what black should do here is
play rook c8
if rook c8 my bishop actually probably
has to go back
and then black can trade it off that
would be a bit easier to play
and black would have time to play a6 and
prevent
this pawn b5 move but yeah once i got h3
[Music]
in it was a pleasant middle game
sloppy wizard thanks for subbing and
hello to
zeleron from turkey nice yeah shout out
to turkey shout out to europe
i guess i'm still being european
friendly with the time
let's suppose i haven't deserved a game
yet
and so far i've just been playing like a
stafford rapper tour
whoa zelda ron is subbing okay i can't
play a stafford here
but i can play i'll play my anti-danish
gambit
a bunch of people subbing there
i've seen this move before what's the
move to play i can just take
place c6 so i
i've won upon
let's pin at night i'm out of any sort
of prep
but i'll just try and develop
move quickly pressure the the pressure
points and thanks so much to
geraldis or geraldis also subbing with
prime
a couple new subs there thanks so much
yeah i'm pretty sure like early
afternoon
at least my time is the best time
overall to stream on twitch
because you maximize the number of
people who are awake
well lugi also thanks for subbing
man all these prime subs thanks people
that's a good move let's move back if
takes takes i'll be threatening the
bishop because the
f pawn is pinned another idea of um
like somehow maneuvering the knight
that's a good move let's retreat
i'm trying to hold my ground be solid
yeah i just want a complete development
yeah so i'm over defining the bishop
otherwise the queen was overworked
this pin is a little bit annoying why
can't i rewind
oh because twitch is weird twitch is not
like youtube
i know a lot of people are used to
youtube where you can just
hit the arrow key and go back in time
i'm pretty sure if you're on if you're
on desktop i'm pretty sure there's a
browser extension which allows you to
rewind on twitch
uh you could go into the vod
which is a little bit
perfect month to re-up some awesome
chess content oh hey
yeah september i forgot that existed but
i think there's discounts on subs
okay let's let's remember that i
berserked
wait my queen
oh no my queen my actual queen
my queens is trapped here that's tragic
and my time too oh this is really bad
my queen's just trapped
okay this is going to take some work i
have 48 seconds and i'm down the queen
okay opponent gives me a little bit back
so now it's queen for rook
this pawn is kind of a headache
i mean sunlight holds things together
kind of let's google eric
yeah i'm gonna need a lot of
a lot of let's go
this is not easy i mean that's the time
situation especially
i mean the main compensation is the form
oh it's a fork
oh but it doesn't better high work play
oh he made an appearance in different
times yesterday
petra yeah no petra has a very fine
opening
ah i'm in big trouble here
um i have any tricks
i have very few tricks here
um
i might as well move the king
this is really bad though
so so now it's again queen for night
um might as well get some g5 in
opponent's opponent has played well this
game
i think my only hope is like some weird
stalemate
oh hello i'm in big trouble here
okay let's keep pushing pawns because
what else to do i'm completely stuck
yeah there goes all my position
i'm not resigning because there's some
like weird stalemate stuff
but not really
or is there
ah there's not oh i lost a game
i lost oh actually the rating loss isn't
too bad
yeah i just i got trapped
the position the position was actually
fine here i think
um this was a really careless move
well played matrix one
okay life goes on um
yeah like after bishop g3 it's hard to
come back
speaking of not being able to rewind
my stream on my phone had a hiccup right
as i announced the research oh no
so i don't know if i predicted oh oh you
missed it
oh i was so proud of it no well
kind of you you basically fed me the
response i was so proud of
being fed your response
so sometimes when you miss something you
can clip it even if you're on mobile you
can clip it
and see the most recent like 30 to 60
seconds
um you can always go back in the future
too okay so maybe i shouldn't berserk
let's hold off him yeah nobody's working
this game my wife
eric is my new best friend but eric
doesn't know that yet
oh
wait is that a is that a good thing or a
bad thing
because it depends on the perspective
bishop g4 bishop g4 is the move
haha yes definitely going back in the
future
yeah except
at least most of us have to just deal
with the present
wait going back in the future
oh maybe referring to the past
also okay this is really nice knight's
pin to f7
uh checkmate okay i needed that that was
like a nice therapy win
especially after that previous game oh
thank you
was wolves with a triple seven inside
subbing a tier one it's a new sub and
mat rob another new sub at tier one
and c v b n v cc something
oh with a wife well i hope wife is good
life is good oh admiral i thought
thousand bits thanks for the win bits
and thanks for the 500 back to the
future bits
and thanks wolves for the 44 leftover
bits
hail hey it's toilet or is it oh no it's
harry krishnan
who said that who said hell
oh it's hari krishnan yeah always trying
to confuse
me die berserk oh i reflexively
berserked
i didn't intend to berserk
so d4 is a funny move d4 we both make
new queens
repeating the the game i had in sonia
lang oh it's gonna happen
let's go um
okay oh this is confusing
let's take here my wife also supports
you
oh a shout out to your wife
uh oh wait my bishop
my beautiful bishop
queen e5 queen variation yeah it's a
four queen variation
it's so beautiful but also slightly
scary
so there's knight d7
i just feel a little bit stuck with the
things
if this were bug house i get made it
immediately
hi future me watching on youtube oh
hello to all the future people
watching on youtube if you're watching
this in the future
it's a present for you
but present time is just future past
right
anyway okay i have very little time but
i have two queens
but white has two queens
and we both or at least i have a past i
have a past eight pawn
i'm seven moves away from making a new
queen
tonight night there is probably oh i
have this move i forgot about this movie
temporal mechanics always gives me a
headache
oh like time
yeah that's okay just take some
painkiller i guess let's take a bishop
i feel claustrophobic seeing this
position oh
cause mike yeah my king has no breathing
room but that's okay it's protected
kind of
[Music]
i wanted to make another queen but my
opponent resigned
so why should they play bishop e3 here
that was really the only move
to save the king and the bishop
exactly what up youtube
okay back to tournament hello present me
oh hello present you
oh do you want to be presented
or no oh it's present oh i have to give
you a present
no pants jake what's up no pants jake
thanks for subbing for four months
okay playing ferrari racer let's
play e4 i'll probably play more london
later in the tournaments there's a
commercial running where a woman says i
love frozen and it sounds just like
i love rosen so i know exactly what
you're talking about i heard that the
other
day and i was like surprisingly
delighted
then i was disappointed that i realized
it said frozen and not risen
but that's okay because we have
enactments in
that once soothes all the pain
okay let's have some fun
uh how does this go again queen d5 right
yeah queen d5
so there's there's two moves and rookie
one let's go
yeah i'll have to remember the line
i made a joke the other day that
nagmansen
is like the baby child of nakamura and
carlson
because it's like if you just merge
their names you get nakmensen
the most powerful thing of all time
this bishop is very powerful
look at this bishop oh it's so powerful
the rook is trapped
oh the rook is so well trapped
if rook f8 queen h5 king d7 queen f5
king here oh wait no i should probably
take the rook
oh there's so many ways to do this
jonathan
is proud oh he would be so proud yeah
shout out to vampire chicken
the the first ever coach of the
nagminson
i think he discovered the nagminton
even before christopher columbus i as
opposed to magnus carlsen can say that
eric has never beaten me in chess
oh that's true yeah congratulations
okay i think the king is going to have
some troubles
queen of seven
where's my win where's my mate we're not
five here here if you merge carlson and
rose and you get
carlson
or you get rosen i don't know
chuck
wait how do i do this
check okay i'll just win a pawn i guess
i won't want to draw no draw though did
you see magnus lose to nakmunson
[Music]
he didn't really accept it but yeah it
was still funny
that's what matters okay the rooks are
op
almost as op as samai
there's a lot of like people in the
youtube comments
saying some iop
where's my mate oh look at this
it's a cool idea so this isn't a check
but it's setting up it's setting up some
beauty
black's gonna play this one i'm gonna
made in two or made in one
so i'm threatening made in two with this
and this
with the rucksack
oh no my rook
okay that was a really feel good game
very feel good nightmansion game
did i miss rook fades
thank you for all the content you are
providing us bits
oh thank you for
the bits bernie einhower
yeah i'm actually wondering if i had
anything better i mean
by the time i got the bishop here it's
winning but
we've got four ah so okay i just needed
to put the other rook into e1
nice nice yeah
i don't get the nightmanson so often
but when i do it's so much fun
all right whoa it's it it's five
thousand bits
thanks so much unfortunately i have to
go to work
had to stop in and throw some bits at
you thanks so much
the tournament goes well i appreciate
that
it's going well so far except for the
one small
berserk hiccup i really appreciate the
bits thanks for stopping by
always nice to see the admiral you can
go back in the vaude and see
see the the first i don't know what it
was the cheer or resub
anyway let's move on and
oh top 50 let's go
okay
could you play a caro can please
no because i'm light
but we'll play a sicilian maybe i'll
play like a grand prix attack or
something
yeah bishop b5 this line
it's a fun line
play a4 hope the throne bits d-i-d-n-t
hurt or the throne bits oh cause you
threw them just don't throw them too
hard
uh what's the line here
this bishop a2 like d5 could be coming
it's a slightly confusing position a lot
of tension between the knights between
the pawns
just have to deal with the tension and
d4 i'll
probably play knight b1
[Music]
i'm still going for like the typical
grand prix setup
probably throwing king h1 at some point
maybe someday pawn storm
whoa watching chess is a very stunning
way
hw i took calc 3
i took calc 3 back in 20
2013. it wasn't fun
i didn't enjoy the the third dimension
of calculus there's too many variables
i hope this helps you soothe the pain
okay so i completed development black
has more space on the queen side but
i have a lot of potential on the king
side
probably go for this and this
i enjoyed calc 2 cow 2 was
i studied really hard in calc 2
but since then i kind of forgot
everything
okay let's play f5 winning connect four
temporarily
um
i should have expected that okay let's
take
five upon f5 that's a good move
i'm playing knight g4
so i'm controlling f4 with the rook
threatening maybe bishop f4
there's also some idea of doubling up on
the a file
that's an interesting position
definitely some potential to attack
very slight time advantage
i'm actually curious like how many
people in the chat are taking calculus
or taking any sort of math course
currently
math used to be my favorite subject way
back when
difficu oh we have a calculus tutor
yeah for anyone struggling with calculus
in the chat
you should reach out to the calculus
tutor in the chat
that's a good move pressure
let's play bishop g5
good evening eric good evening stream
erin pilgrim welcome back
yeah trying to be friendly to the
europeans
also thanks so much aaron pilgrim sent
me a postcard from
remote region of russia i'm still in the
process
of trying to figure out how to build a
shelf
but once i build the shelf i'll be
displaying all the
all the gifts and postcards people have
sent
what to do here
you could take play queen e4 maybe just
centralize the queen
um that should be close to equal
but okay i have some initiative the
rook's tied down to the back rank
might be worth playing g4 here there's
also this move
just controlling the file
don't mind this king f8 could be
annoying to prepare this
but then there's always rook a8
yeah white's probably slightly better
just with the
like the structure blacks a bit tied
down i have more useful pieces
this pawn is a permanent weakness
pawn looks potentially weak but i always
have g4
and king g2
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if h6
happens or h5
or g6 wow okay let's put the rook back
on f1
yeah with g6 there could be some issues
with king safety for black
okay now i have f6 but f6 queen e3
it gets weird
i'm not sure what to make of that king
h2
i really don't know i have this move too
why do mathematicians confuse halloween
and christmas
because december 25th october 31st
i don't know if i understand this oh
desu oh yeah like das
oct whatever that means
oh base 10 and base eight oh okay
i think i understand that
but i don't know if i understand this
position
[Music]
play rook i'm scared of rook here here
so i'm calculating rook off three rooks
here king h2 rook c2 rook g3
whoa it's a raid oh it's a king crusher
raid thanks king crusher appreciate that
let's start with let's start with king
here oh i just lost a lot of time
if you're just joining i'm playing the
yearly blitz arena all right so shout
out to king crusher this time
greetings from germany oh greetings to
germany
yeah uh guten morgen
or whatever german words do i know nine
and danka okay um
let's focus my time is precious
i have this move
my time is very precious i want to go
for rook f3 next
i'm down a minute if you're just joining
i was getting distracted earlier by
mathematics um but i do appreciate
all the king crusher fans joining um
king crusher has been a long time
streamer
on twitch started streaming chats on
twitch before
most people on this planet
people should give them a follow check
them out
okay i want to go for f6
okay we're gonna have to go into some
some end game
[Music]
not super thrilled about this
i'll try and make it work
and there's some hopes just to like play
quickly and went on time
but i'd like to maintain oh i lied
rookie two
okay let's go for this and then king e5
i'll try and try and win the pawn
rook before then i'm just dominating
maybe king d6
f6 first and then king d6
i'm trying to orchestrate some mating
idea
okay rookie six coming
oh it's getting intense i want to play
rook a7
let's go for this
my pawn
okay let's do this
close okay i'm up on time that's what
matters
okay i was really close final position
i'm
just probably worse but that worked out
there are ten kinds of people in the
world those who understand hexadecimal
and efforts
is that another math joke or is that
just bullying people
i don't know i think it's for the bits
okay so i'm i'm top 40.
uh i still have to play budapest
why do skiers like linear equations why
because it's easy to find the slope oh i
understand that one
what's the equation for slope mx plus b
or no oh m is a slope though
i think it's been so long
it's been so long since i've been in
school okay i'm playing a
ray robson variation of the catalan
yeah c5 is like the start of the the
variation
this used to be super rare it's been a
bit more common recently
um yeah queen a4 is a move and then 95
is
kind of expected and white's going to
win a pawn
probably or multiple pawns
there goes all my pawns there goes this
pawn
there's a funny trap though yeah this is
this is a funny trap black is winning
now
this is all opening preparation i
discovered this line
close to 10 years ago inspired by ray
robson
i think i discovered this with the
engine actually years ago
okay how to exploit the king if i play
queen g5 there's f4
just play queen elizabeth overrun yeah
i have to calculate the slope of this
diagonal
oh rise over run oh so the slope of this
is just
one right
i think
uh what's hanging oh i have a tricky
move
look at this tricky move it takes i pin
and then probably win
meanwhile the queen's tied down to the
knight which is now undefended i have
knight b3
uh i'll play knight b3 first white's
pieces are just sidelined
the king is a little bit stranded
i have queen c7 here
oh i forgot about that move but i have
this move
these pieces are stuck i'm threatening
made in one
also probably the pawn is yeah the d4
pawn is hanging
that's a nice opening it's a fun opening
against the catalan you need some
preparation
but there's a lot of lines where white
can fall victim just like this
this is probably one of the like the
most natural approaches for white is to
like
try and win the back the pawn like this
is very typical
catalan play and then that's unfortunate
for white that this just
wins on the spot for black okay
hey 23rd
[Music]
okay so i've i'm within reach
of top 10. this could be a long
tournament
maybe a long stream oh thanks biscuit
fiend
resolving for 10 months sharing the
formula for slope
yeah delta delta x over delta y
right or something like that oh that's
not berserk
i'm playing first place
oh strong player it looks like okay i'm
playing a london because why not
london time queen c7 popular line
um so i think the approach is to take
here
oh opponent is prepared wow let's play
this move
and then the approach is just to go for
e4
there's a trap knight c6 knight b3 wins
a piece for white why can't the number
four get into the nightclub
why because he's too square oh
oh i have a joke why why couldn't the
minor piece
get into the nightclub because he was a
bishop
and not a knight
okay so i'm going for e4 um
now i studied this recently and i forgot
all my prep
but i have some idea of forking
eventually
i'm actually wondering i just play e4
immediately
takes rook b1 takes an e5
yolo
i might as well try and make my opponent
think rather than me trying to calculate
for a minute
what did zero say nice belt
another six decent move play bishop c2
or bishop
and play bishop c2 being sneaky
this i do this london where you trade
dark square bishops on f4
oh sometimes usually by accident but
that's a trendy line
kante's been playing it a bit as well as
andrew tang
[Music]
the london gods play this move
kind of like the position nice and sharp
oh i missed attack oh did i maybe i
didn't
at first i thought i missed this this
and then this but then there'd be this
and black defense
but there is there's some tactical
potential
these variations
bishop b5 i'm wondering if i can play c4
and there's also just queen f3 i'll
start with queen f3
this could get very very sharp very
quickly
maybe bishop h4
might as well just applying additional
pressure
there's a lot of pressure points here
okay the first thing i see is this and
this bishop and pawn are
geometrically involved i don't know if i
can actually exploit it
fully
it's close though
hmm
i broke just have rook he one and bishop
g3 back
i um my pawn on f4
calculate knight g4
doesn't seem so effective though
that's something
i'm playing the g4
that's probably not leading to too much
i'm just realizing like if the queen
lands on h4 which is very possible
there's pressure against the rook
so we could end up trading everything
get some bishop ending
man i lost a lot of time been perplexed
about this opening
or more about the middle game it's f5
too
it's not too scary though i don't think
where's the queen go
f5 probably queen g3
might be the only move because queen h
fighters queen f4
why wasn't the geometry teacher at
school because she sprained her
angle
okay um let's try and stay focused oh
dear
i just realized i might be losing
oh no
because here
because g5 happens oh no
[Music]
i'm in big trouble oh maybe bishop here
that's not good for me but might be the
only try
ah not what i wanted wow opponent was
expecting that
that's a very powerful move
okay i have queen f3 attacking b7
which i think maybe black missed the
queen takes a2 is not so
bad i don't think unless it is
to go for this
i've got both bishops attacked queen a1
bishop b1
f4 okay four's only move
really i can take though
just take both bishops
wow some crazy moves
some really crazy moves here
wow am i losing probably just losing
here
[Music]
well played that was a nice tactical
combination
by my opponent
okay but i'm still kind of alive my time
[Music]
okay black allowed this thankfully
i'm very much alive here it's all about
not flagging
okay everything's offended now
how i'm surviving this but i am
da my pawns
at least i can safely pre-move kind of
i have this move
no my my rook
uh
ah oh that was a weird game
man
well i was proud to get to this position
objectively this is probably close to
winning for white
if i had more time but i didn't have
more time
maybe by here it's kind of tricky
because my things are falling
um
yeah it got really complicated there
my g4 was not a good move
yeah i just allowed f5 was a nice
combination
yeah this idea was really nice okay
rookbeet immediately is even stronger
wow okay life goes on
that was only the second loss that i've
had okay
can't be too disappointed i could play
zen mode
but too late i'll just try
to keep playing chess
um opponent berserking i'll bring it
back
our openings hard work and low reward
it depends on the level i guess at a
higher level they're
they're hard work but also high reward
at lower levels maybe that statement's
more true hey it's kimmy what's up kimmy
how's it going shout out to kimmy and
thank you to
let's go something something
something for five months okay we have a
very
boring symmetrical position
i used to play this a lot when i was
like first learning chess
like every game would be like this and
then
at some point i'd just kind of get
confused what to do
nowadays i understand some general plans
mike can come here pawn can come here
maybe some potential for a king side
attack
that's a weird move it does restrict the
knight though
the problem with g3 is why can't castle
now because this pawn needs
a babysitter mainly this rook
now the knights pinned to the pawn
not sure if i can exploit it
oh i had this move and then this move
but i'm still threatening this
we might repeat and then i might go for
this
i'm not sure though should also go for
probably just go for a5
hi eric can you shout out to another
kimmy oh
shout out to another kimmy are there
multiple kimmies oh i forgot to type in
the shout out
shout outs kimmy lou 18.
thanks for being here and yeah whoever
the other kimmy is
maybe imposter kimmy
i'm sure out of probably out of like all
the members in the chat
there's many people sharing names with
each other problem do german students
have trouble answering
9. do you know what the square root of
81 is
oh because they say nine but that means
no right
i don't know i have to brush up on my
[Music]
german to do
let's attack oh there's so many good
looking moves here i'll play queen g5
looks fun so i'm putting the pawn
actually knight f4 is a more of a
monster threat
yeah and i left f4 if the king moves
here i take this with check or if the
king moves here i take
with the bishop with chuck
yeah 93 9 f4 it's looking good
am i playing the whole four hours i'm
not sure i don't like to make
i might get tired at some point
i'll probably fall asleep
but hopefully not on stream
okay knight controls h8 which is clutch
what oh that's a move
i'm kind of butchering this but time
will
will be my savior
uh
let's actually check on d2
oh what is this
where's my win oh there's a cool idea
i just want to play
i just want to move my king with
checkmates
or move my rook with checkmate i was
envisioning like the king being here the
rook being here
and then playing king g8 checkmate but
this worked too
okay so
i guess i mean if i can stay within like
the top standings
and be competitive in the overall like
tournament standings
i might play for at least a couple more
hours
but we'll see we'll play it by ear i'm
not too tilted yet
oh oh i'm playing this person again who
beat me so it's time for revenge
hopefully we're gonna have oh
kind of a standard qgd
we're gonna see a catalan or main line
e3 e3 is playable we're just gonna play
standard
castle etc
idea of a6 is to take play b5 c5
gain some time uh b3 is very solid
i can take if it takes i'll play c5
otherwise
i'll get my setup
it's gonna be hard to fight for first
especially if this person keeps winning
but let's put up a fight to learn from
the previous game
and my opponent's not perfect it
definitely makes mistakes
just have to keep up the tempo they do
play fast
let's go let's go oval stingray welcome
back
thanks for subbing for three months
and i feel like you've been here for
longer
and thank you mystery band appreciate
that oh
gifted by payphone okay let's uh let's
try and stay focused
95 is some idea
i might have to play c5 here and that's
a typical move
so i prevent knight a5 i'm kind of
making the bishop happy
but now i'm challenging white's
mean center pawn
put the reconcite
could take first bishop f3 may be coming
[Music]
i'll take first pawn takes my d5
i actually don't know how to play that
game i've seen like a few clips of it
i'm not entirely sure how it works i
just know that there's imposters
and sometimes people lie
okay let's play bishop d6 just want to
optimize my position
probably queen e7 rook ed8
it's the main plan maybe bishop ba too
can take with rook good day with the
rook
feels a little bit strange but okay i
pressure the thing
some potential for a lift
oh the rematch hopefully soon to be
revenge bits
the sweetest form of revenge
but okay at least time is better this
game like equal time
we both have the bishop hair we could be
heading towards some end game
there's some weird line like takes takes
rook c1 rook d2
takes i take here and i'm turning this
and this
and defending this
but this could branch out in many
different directions
queen c2 is another move so queen d5
there's bishop f3
[Music]
i'm thinking bishop d6 here like this
bishop doesn't really do much on c5
anyway
rook here i play queen b8 probably
just exert pressure might see f4 at some
point
nice thing about queen b8 is it enables
rook c8
f4 would weaken the pawn
[Music]
okay probably bishop c7
[Music]
yeah trying to restrict the light as
much as possible
now sneakily attacking the pawn
i'm wondering if i can bishop h294
it's almost kind of cool i can start
with this move actually
[Music]
maybe not
okay bishop bishop e4 bishop d3
i was trying too hard to make bishop h2
work
oh what to do
maybe play queen eight
actually let's first try let's first
play rook c8
so i over defend the bishop basically
painting the knight
knight moves anywhere i have this move
and now i play queen eight
okay that didn't really do too much or
did it
oh opponent giving me a taste of my own
medicine
that's a good move 98
this was not preferable
and we both have this like weird queen
corner bishop battery
should bishop c2
[Music]
bishop c2 is kind of nifty
motivation subscription oh i feel
motivated now thanks so much veldrivath
and things are getting spicy not sure
what's happening here knight c4
i can take take take
take take i lose a pawn
this could get really weird really
quickly i can win a pawn because the
queen's overworked
but then bishop h8 threading made on g7
[Music]
okay none of that happens
hmm
thinking queen d5 that's probably no
good though
put the bishop back
it's passive not thrilled about this
knight c7 maybe holds things together
oh thanks for whoa it's kimmy gifting
subs thanks so much kimmy
i'm trying but it's complicated i feel
i feel like i'm getting outplayed again
unfortunately but okay the bishop
defends his pawn knight defends this
pawn
queen c8 we trade i play knight t7
ooh that's a good move
it's actually a really annoying move am
i just losing
because queen b8 there's bishop e5 man
i'm oh that doesn't work either
queen see it
i think i'm just losing man
where are my tricks i'm just losing here
that's so sad
okay let's play queen d5 and hopefully
my opponent will forget about the
knights
turning this
there's very few tricks i can pull
okay i just want bishop d6
ideas have a5 ideas too
that's a good move
am i getting mated not sure here here
here here probably getting flagged
i got mated at least i didn't flag this
time around
ah i gotta play it was a tricky middle
game
why was more more tricky
more resourceful
yeah bishop f8 it's a sign that things
are going wrong after bishop f8
there's too many too many things to
worry about
oh russian oh that's me thanks
gregory253
and thanks again kimmy gifting subs to
oh kimmy says adios you are still
curious how to pronounce youtube
ceo's name type would you like shitsuke
right that's the original version
oh interesting okay let's tilt berserk
yeah i think skimming gifting subs to no
i know something something and principle
one two three
okay let's try and re revive
my spirits within that manson oh
d5 opponent wasn't expecting
a magnuson what to play against d5
just take that
and bishop takes actually forgot what to
play here
because d5 is is pretty rare
like usually they take and then play d5
i think i have to take with knight
actually
then bishop e6
maybe i do take with bishop
there's some line takes takes we trade
queens
it's funny my opponent just pre-moved d5
expecting like the main line
i think mainline like is rookie one
okay there's no bishop f7 there's rookie
one
but then bishop f5 okay let's take
okay equal material down a lot of time
but
that's what i get for berserking oh
hello to tikong how's it going
and mccorgo redeeming sip tea but i'm
actually sipping coffee
don't get mad at me
and thank you daniel j lange slimming at
tier one
appreciate that you lost free queen what
does that mean
can you lose something that's free
black lost a free pawn
i won a free pawn but i'm also losing oh
but the knight's hanging
um i can take this
okay this is working out really nicely
the only concern is this and this
what to do and this there's this ugly
thing
which i might have to do
i also know i don't have i have this
man i'm trying to figure out the best
the best course of action
[Music]
i'll just uh i'll be extra safe
put the bishop on e1 that's a sad square
but
i have two minors for
the rook
i just want to make a looft
yeah the rook defends a bishop from a
distance okay let's push the pawn attack
there we go okay glad to see you on i
was watching your youtube videos earlier
as opening prep
oh nice walden pawn thanks for subbing
nice to hear now you can watch live
on twitch uh let's play this
move okay i want to go for the
the kingside attack my time is very
precious
king f8 bishop f6
i just want to go for like some kind of
quick mates oh wait
my knight ah i just i plundered a night
out of nowhere
thankfully i it might still be okay
the pawn is if the pawn takes like when
the bishop
oh this is really nice yeah king here i
take
threading this if takes i check check
and then queen
there's not even rook f8 because my pawn
captures diagonally
so this kind of accidentally worked out
in my favor
[Music]
okay threatening this forgot about king
g6
it's just a matter of converting
so here here here here here
okay this is mating
oh it's a skewer too okay that was nice
so 35th place oh i'm trying to break
2500
i'll play a stafford never played oh no
staff for this game
maybe some italian oh i'm accidentally
playing for two nights
i got tricked into it two nights oops
i'm playing a tricky line the main line
was knight a5
this line is kind of nifty idea b5
f3 f3 is so random i don't think i've
ever seen f3 before
so threatening the knight
this looks pleasant take the bishop play
f5 bishop c5
i can't complain with this
todd in holland is just down the street
thanks for mentioning them now i have
loads of excellent tea
they are on sale oh that's awesome
yeah here's if you can see
it kind of says todd in holland yeah i
got
i got all these like different tea packs
it's so good
it's like high quality loose leaf they
uh they import from
china and japan
place he what to do here
could just castle yeah no rush
oh there's a cool idea
oh there's a really cool idea
involving oh involving queen sac leading
to double checkmates
okay so i'm threatening maiden wait a
minute one two three four
five six
wait i can't count i want to do this
it almost works the problem is knight h5
takes and then here
oh knight e2 f4 mate oh that's so cool
so just to explain okay the the main the
first calculation is takes takes
rook h6 king g1 knight e2 or knight f3
it's double checkmates in this case
double double checkmate because there's
two options both leading to double check
and mate
and if knight h5 so it takes takes
knight h5 takes king here
not f4 immediately but 92 clearing the
bishop
i can only take two different ways and
then i mate
so i sack the queen
and then i potentially sack the knight
as well
it's so nice
yeah so i'm going to sack the knights
the bishops play
a crucial role along with the rook and
pong
and other pawn
oh it's not meat oh no i got too excited
i forgot the knight defends oh but the
king's on f what is this
oh dear wait ah i was so confident
life goes on
i guess life goes on oh that's so tragic
i have 40 i have 41 seconds
i spent all the time like drawing those
beautiful arrows
down i'm getting forked wait a minute
what's going on hello youtube oh hello
kind of people what is this position
this is so confusing i've i'm down the
queen for a bishop
but the king is very
uh checkmateable maybe bishop g3 ideas
oh no my rook my rook
please take it
yes wow
man it was a miscalculation i got way
too
too confident too arrogant
now i was so proud of this like 92 finds
okay at least that worked out hello to
youtube
what was that game beautiful oh
you're beautiful too pimp jesus 420
i'm wondering if like this actually
works hello youtube
like maybe f4 is better oh hello oh
twitch
says hello youtube people
say hi to twitch chat
so they're not lonely
even though you're maybe the same person
or same people
wait is there a force mate
it's so close to force mate f4 king f2
okay i could win the queen back
and then have like a slightly better
position
okay so knight e2 is like a terrible
move
even though it's still okay it's still
unclear maybe
oh rook g5 okay let's look at f4 king f2
knight c2 kimi
2 okay i take the queen and life is good
is there anything better than queen h2 i
could just play rook h6
that's less fancy though
at this point oh it's still interesting
yeah the king was kind of
misplaced
oh wait oh white has d4 here apparently
hello eric and hello youtube hope you
have a great day
oh thanks so much you too
youtube oh you can't spell youtube
without youtube
huh thanks great time
i love such nice bait
such nice bait if i ever go fishing to
remember to bring this rook
okay let's go back
trying to re-enter the top 30. i've
re-entered the 2500 club
playing kaiser susie let's
playa london london time
i've never played among us but i might
be
peer pressured into doing it at some
point
okay bishop b5 this is kind of new
theory
hey it's joe broome what's up joe bruhn
let me move all i've
yeah i grabbed all the tea this is
actually a nice tea
it's has a cool name
anyway um i'll play c4 and let's give a
shout out
joe brune good to see you
so yeah this is actually a very tricky
line
uh main idea is if takes i play a4 in
defending the bishop
and then i want to recapture with the
knights and apply as much pressure as
possible to this knight
before blocking castle
and there's some really weird lines here
wait maurizevich offered me to stream
oh i don't know
if he can if he can follow up um
i'll try and look for his message there
there were several days where i just
like bogged down so it may have slipped
through the cracks
i can reach out to him too um thanks for
letting me know
yeah maurizavich is like a strong very
strong player
i didn't realize he's streaming though
okay we have some very weird position
here i gave up casting rights
i'm trying to take away blacks casting
rights
um to do maybe queen b3
so threatening to take or just
threatening to take immediately
have i ever made it by taking on passant
i've been close
but not that i can remember
definitely not on stream
it's a hard thing to achieve
bishop e7
it's going to be hard to stop black from
castling
there's this
not sure here
let's play this move i'm going to try
and win the pawn
i'm expecting back to castle and then
we can actually trade a little bit
i'm gonna have some issues to solve
um
now let's go for this
[Music]
yeah i'd definitely be down to stream
with morozovic um
that would be cool
it's best for him to uh
to email me probably or just to whisper
me on twitch
play visual d2
do i get a reference
i feel like joe bruhn knows more
references than me unfortunately
but maybe it's a good thing
oh so i'm still up a pond but
these pawns don't
doesn't really feel like a majority
the black's probably better here
objectively
oh maybe morozev streams on youtube
which is why i wasn't aware of him
streaming
i know there's a lot of chess players
now just not streaming on twitch but
streaming on youtube
which is probably a better like growth
strategy
at least for newer streamers
this position is very unpleasant
okay bishop e3
trying to figure out how i can give back
a pawn and just not
collapse completely i could just try and
hold on to everything
this is so ugly though
like takes takes all my pawns are
isolated
a couple sets of double pawns i'm still
up a pawn
i'm realizing if king g2 here i can't
play rook f1 because knight e3
oh this is really really bad
so the question is how to fight there's
a bishop e1 sad move
maybe no i'm singing rig h2
you just don't see what to do here
okay i'll start with this
i might just have to like hunker down
and let black take all my pawns
that's kind of terrifying
knight d3 coming
[Music]
knight d3 rook f1
oh let's play rogue f1
pray for the best
and it's gonna take a big miracle to
survive this
let's go after this pawn
go after this pawn some more
oh that's a good move
okay so if takes i play rook b1
i'm just going for counter play so i'm
down okay i was up upon earlier now i'll
be down the pawn
uh bring the key towards the center
it's all about trying to activate as
much as possible
i think the rook would be decent on a5
apply constant pressure
[Music]
i want to go for rook g8 da
let's play f3 in rook g8
still matrix
okay
i was so difficult to like survive oh
the whole game was just torture
man
[Music]
yeah like with the king on h1 of course
like i'm i'm hoping for stale matrix
the problem is with this setup i always
have g2 so i had to wait for the pawn to
come here
which it did eventually and actually
it's funny like after f3
it's just it's um it's a theoretical
draw
f3 literally loses all the pawns
because i just take i i'm able to take
on e3 and that f3
like no matter what and i win h2 as well
okay good thing i didn't flag i was
close to flagging
okay
good luck oh thanks for the bits
maha roberto uh i'll play e4
okay oh carol khan i'll play a
accelerated panel of
that was a mouse slip but this is
actually working out i meant to play
queen b3 immediately
bishop here i have this
okay let's develop
okay so what is this position
to prevent black from castling
i have to be careful here
95 so defending
attacking stuff
a7 is kind of hanging okay there's more
important things
i got a six move smothered mate against
ah i know that line wanted to do a video
about that line
at some point congratulations
anton zero i'm proud of you
what's going on here
this position is so confusing
i feel like i should have tactics but
not seeing them let's just castle
my black has potential tactics too
i'm gonna lose a pawn i guess
i guess i'm losing back the pawn
oh there's a cool idea speaking of
smothered mate
do i queen sack i kind of want a queen
sack
there's bishop e60 unfortunately oh but
my queen's trapped
i'm gonna have to queen sack
oh wow
add me on league nice nine what
okay let's take take bishop e6 expected
then i can take this way
league knight is nine i don't know what
that means
okay opponent doesn't do not see bishop
e6
idea knight f6
not sure if this is actually working
though maybe bishop f6 is a better idea
check
a very confusing position
everything's in shambles for both of us
okay that's a free queen
what's material i'm down the exchange
i'm down the exchange but i have weird
pieces
i'm threatening this
also bishop's pressure
okay there we go
oh i look i forgot b2 is hanging
here goes all my pawns
let's just go for the mating attack
okay
our g one's passive but what else to do
i wanna put the knight there
go for this
now this is pretty bad
unless it's not too bad
no
ah
that was a nice position i think i don't
know
i don't know what to make of this uh
this game the queen got trapped
i guess i didn't really see this coming
but
it was still it was still interesting
oh did i have stalemate traps i was
maybe close
had the same pattern with the king and
pawn
actually yeah i should have been more
[Music]
i should have tried to allow the king to
take and then sack the rook
i was actually more focused on trying to
like get a rook to g8
but of course i was too slow i could
take the pawn here
that's unfortunate
uh
okay life moves on let's go back to
tournament
48th place
it's tough it's getting competitive
which is galco man this um it's probably
an anonymous like strong player
okay let's observe let's try and fight
back
stafford gambit time maybe
whoa apple bow gifting subs thanks so
much
stafford gambit declined thanks so much
gifting 10 subs
really appreciate that gifting to
cutford
adrian lenny hh3
captain clutch no drip there no thumb
swim and ginger bead jack
bishop g5 is a move
and go for this kind of attack
pedro 2393 and boki
underscore
everyone who has gifted the sub say
thank you tom lobo really appreciate
that
i also appreciate my attack
so like in the stafford gambit declined
it's kind of a
stable position for both sides but
there's there's some nice attacking
potential for black
um especially with the queen now
the queen should take a step back and
then
[Music]
allow for the bishop to come in
debating whether i should do something
just
carry on with the plan
now i want to apply as much pressure to
the knight
as possible
is the stafford your main response for
the petrov
so the stafford is like a gambit within
the petrov
so i'm not sure if that question makes
sense
like when i'm light and i play against
the petrov
i guess i have a few options i showed a
line in a recent video
where you can play a reverse stafford
gambit it's called the
the bowden kaiser ritsky gambit
um but yeah i mean these days if i'm
playing
like a speed speed game online blitzer
bullets
if i'm playing a petrov i'm intending to
go for a stafford
and usually my my thought process is
i'll i'll check if i've ever played the
opponent before and if i've never played
them before
then they're probably getting a stafford
um
if they're an e4 player
but more and more people are like
studying what to do for white these days
so i have to be a bit more careful but
it's still working a lot
had a few successful ones this
tournament
okay so we both have double c pawns
the position is a bit more active for
black with the battery
h3 might come if h3 i'm probably okay
getting some end game
and white's gonna have an additional set
of double pawns
if i play rook e8 there's uh there's
bishop b5
which i probably don't want to allow
i'm gonna play a slow move a6
just depriving the bishop of b5 square
now i can fight for the files yeah we're
going to play very positionally
let's trade off everything and with a
pawn structure even though there's pawns
on both sides usually a bishop is
preferable
in this sort of case i think the knight
will be a strong piece
um
even though yeah so like white has more
more king activity
but there's potential to just get an
outpost on
on f4 to watch out for this move
the king is almost getting mated
actually controlling these squares
can control these squares too
you always play f6
if king here i can win the pawn and lose
a pawn
it'd be nice to have like some
unexpected mate in the center of the
board
probably not happening
there's a lot of lines where white just
loses h3
hmm
i have g6 let's play g6 okay so the
king's gonna come back and save the pawn
but oh my time
did i berserk this game i deserved this
game i forgot
at least okay the position is um
[Music]
it should be easy to play
so everything's under control
that's pawn it's kind of a weakness for
the target to attack
probably want to go for d5
um
it'd be funny if like bishop goes here
never mind
doesn't say c4 would kind of shut out
the bishop
okay here's a fork that i was waiting
for
king has to move to g3 so i win a pawn
that's really all i need is one pawn i
can probably trade down or win another
pawn
okay now the bishop has no squares
i'll just go for the c4 break
i should have enough time
mike probably wants to be on d5
i can i can pick up all the pawns
actually
that's a fork
that queen g8 will be made
okay that was a positional kind of end
game
i kind of lost track of time for a
moment there
um i i think it was a nice example of
like kind of this
knight vs bishop imbalance um
because it was hard for white to
actually like exploit any weaknesses
and these like white white had more
weaknesses
which is the long term
um cheese fates thanks for the bits
gg and gl for the rest of the tournament
appreciate that
and welcome yeah welcome to the new
people i saw there was a comment from
someone hey eric good old charlie brown
thanks for all the great content oh i'm
playing chicago okay i have to focus
welcome good little charlie charlie
brown thanks for your comments
thank you to g-step for subbing for two
months
so jacako i've i've tried stafford
gambit on before
uh and it doesn't work against gigaco
glad to catch you in the presence
i have an idea future for once okay if
we're both berserking
i know what i'm gonna play i'll play
this weird opening
because he usually plays d4
this is probably a terrible decision i
just want i want to get a stafford
gambit
uh yeah that's a good move
i've studied this a little bit it's a
bad opening but
hopefully he doesn't refute it so
quickly
um bishop here
oh is this move
yeah the problem is h3 but after h3 the
pawn's pinned
so i'll have one extra tempo to do
something maybe
like castling i don't know what's castle
oh no i blundered oh but i have this
move
tricky move
bishop can't be taken i played this move
no that's too much just show some
respect
why did this move oh but then knight e4
um let's have some fun
showing no respect to strong grandmaster
opponent
to play in the style of the gambit
uh maybe f5
five looks fun d4 queen here
yeah why not
this is probably really bad but i'm
trying to drain his time
confusing position still down the pawn
but these pawns look
funny that's probably a good move
so i can take a five point f6
oh i can't take in the end though
i have to try it
ah that's not good queen here maybe
idea queen h7 and meaning
ah there's bishop f4 i can't take
immediately either
[Music]
g6 maybe no g6 doesn't work
oh there's a funny line though or i mean
g3
let's try g3 idea to take
i'm really showing no respect
wait a minute that didn't work at all i
have this move
okay i have some h file pressure
and the idea is to eventually stack on
d4 because yolo
oh maybe g6 and then i take on d4
but then knight e3 let's try this first
bishop e3 coming
it's still kind of funny
and my pawns perplexed play this move
attack a bishop
always play king b8
and running out of resources
do
do
do
let's go oh what a dirty game
i feel so dirty uh i really showed no
respect
i showed no respect at all i feel bad
he's such a good player but i mean the
the whole point of the opening was to
like try and confuse
how many cells
oh not enough sacks or too many i don't
know
there's never no such thing as too many
socks
yeah yeah and i have three is one of
like
like taking is also really good for
lights but
that was a weird weird position actually
yeah
i feel bad about feeling good about that
but it was a funny opening it's probably
just all bad
but okay in blitz yeah like plus six
already for white
and blitz it's all about initiative and
creating tricky threats
man stockfish is just insulting me
thanks everyone for all the the
congratulatory bits
wondering if i had anything
after this like queen c5 was the best
move
otherwise like i'm the knight defender
rook so i'd be losing a piece
you did him so dirty he p-punched his
table
oh is he streaming oh
i'll have to re-watch the clip of him i
think he was yeah he's streaming
probably on youtube
ny streamer nym and strong
yeah whatever that means
use this bits to buy some flag
disinfectant oh
i have now's probably a good time to
sanitize my hands
okay nice win oh thank you big alex
six nine appreciate that and yeah thanks
everyone for the
the bits thanks jvops va
jayvox for something with prime
i don't care about stockfish we still
love you
oh i love you too thanks volo also
subbing okay playing check a b
zerk let's play e4 i feel a renewed
sense of energy
carol khan time pam of attack
hello to ty blackburn oh i studied this
actually recently
um what's the line queen here
oh this is actually um
oh what is this line i
take free pawn i think i'm winning a
pawn here
it's actually extra good because black
either has to do this ugly move or this
ugly move
okay so i took away black's casting
rights
i want to play rookie one queen is
actually very comfy
on a3
i'm just going to sack the d4 pawn like
if black can take it a few different
ways
take here first take here and then take
here
actually i don't know if it's a actual
sack
because i'll have rook d1 and there's
cases where the queen is tied down
oh but if i play rook d1 now there's
bishop f2
king f2 queen d1 bishop g5 queen d7
i'll play bishop g5
it's a funny position kind of wide open
so i've connected the rook so now i'm
threatening rook d1
also basically tying down the queen so
i'm threatening this too
queen is overworked currently
we might see f6
opponent has time to think
i probably should take with queen i
might be
losing this pawn but okay the the files
look so nice
and the the big problem for black is the
fact that
the rook will be stuck for a while oh
free rook
i was gonna see it yeah opponent resigns
with
without giving me the pleasure of taking
potentially both rooks
okay that was a nice game that was much
cleaner than the previous game
so top 20 let's go right above jesus
frankenstein
playing gilovich have a good score
against this opponent
um i'll play something normal
play d5 oh let's play uh reverse london
yeah this is playable let me go for the
setup
g3 expected
that's also a move so there's some weird
idea like this
this uh g4 and then knight d7
i think is usually the way people go so
counter-attacking
so if takes takes i can play that and if
here i preserve the bishop
oh that's nifty i wonder if i can play
this
then g7 would hang
there's also no g5 doesn't work
okay so white's getting the bishop here
but maybe i'll get the h file
i think i'll castle queenside
yeah it's an interesting position
like maybe castling queenside too and go
after this pawn
it looks like a a grand prix attack
it was like the same structure as a
grand prix
this is normally the move f5 this would
be c4
okay i don't want to trade queens
yeah usually i have a bishop along this
diagonal oh that's a really good move
i'm in trouble i'm probably in trouble
okay i have c4 trying to make things
complicated
95 probably doesn't work or does it
not e5 actually might save me c4 is also
interesting looking
so i deal with c4 is takes i take here
and things kind of get weird
i lose an exchange but there's some
attack
with 95
first question is which knight to move
to e5
so the main idea is to meet f4 with
oh i should move this knight so i defend
the pawn and then meet f4 with
f6 d4 is also met with f6
or just taking and taking here
i think it's okay
i'm probably gonna wind up with triple
pawns triple g pawns
but that would mean i i could have all
three of these pawns
live on g5 potentially
i could get this pawn to g5 then later
this pawn then
we can have triple g5 maybe
okay not the prettiest structure
actually the knight wants to be here
like one typical maneuver is this
this but it's too slow
that's a good move too
all right that's not what i want to do
i'm wondering if i can gab it actually
a gamut thing actually kind of looks fun
like takes and then
no c4 realizing
oh white doesn't take it
this is still not great
let's do this maneuver
okay
i'm kind of suffering
this pawn's kind of weak it's an idea to
push
like the big problem is this bishop i
don't have a lightsword bishop to
contest
and the f5 files in white's full control
and this bishop has no
great squares except e7
i should probably play bishop e7
okay still alive i'm down the minute
oh a lot of people are adding me in the
chat i can't look at the chat though
because
things are are getting heated
can i trade all the rooks
trade all the rooks
i'm tie down to d5
rook d7
there's so many problems with this
position
i can't even play d4 because it takes
and i lose a bishop
challenge vertical connect four oh
so you mean quadruple pawns so i need to
get this that might be difficult
i i got vertical connect three
not sure if that counts for anything
yes i'm losing a pawn
this bishop is so strong
have any hope maybe c no not c4 maybe c4
no
this is so difficult
like i'm trying to figure out where my
chances are
of surviving this like it's not
time
like there's so little counter play so
it's probably just a matter of hunkering
down and trying to move quickly
but yeah chances are pretty slim
okay let's bring the king in
so i'm down two pawns d4 coming too
maybe some obstacle bishop position
let's go for b5
or not
yeah this is really painful
i resigned yeah i just got outplayed man
um i'm trying to identify things
probably went wrong here
just this f pawn is too weak i should
have
sensed danger
and develop my bishop sooner
developing the bishop would have avoided
those problems oh but
some this diagonal maybe f6n
f6 is playable
[Music]
yeah i had knight g5 right away i'm
wondering if
c4 is better
yeah this maybe could have offered me
slightly more chances
what to do yeah at the end it was just
lost
maybe i mouse slipped i don't know
anyway okay
still a decent tournament top 30 still
first place is yet to be caught or
playing check a b
again who i beat
oh we had that quick caro khan game
i have not yet played the budapest
everyone's avoiding it with knight f3 on
move two
but we have a london i don't think i
played against london this tournament
i have mainline london
f5 yeah bishop f5 and then h6
is that the fridge
find the fridge i thought i turned the
fridge off
maybe i didn't turn it off all the way
uh bear with me just a moment i'm to
turn off the fridge because i feel like
there's more background noise now
yeah it was not turned off all the way
okay plenty of time
this is actually a really pleasant
position
i see the new budapest course
i did not
um ah black stopped my plan
or i'll white stop my plan i wanted to
get a knight here
play this move idea f6
also preventing black or preventing
white from castling
didn't really help though let's play f6
anyway
yeah e4 comes
i think my plan is to maneuver
and to still try and get the knight to
a4
that's a wise move
like 93 attacks upon i'll defend
now the fridge is still making noise but
it should quiet hopefully
soon
ah to be careful of
how i proceed here rookie seven and then
rook
he8
okay optimizing the position
slowly but surely
oh i'm getting forked don't do it
i am excited to get my z badge soon oh
hey it's xy sparks i'm
[Music]
excited for you too but not as excited
wait what am i trying to say this
position is less exciting
about the prospect of your z badge
which i do here and white has so much
time too
so my my only hope is to counter fork
which is not gonna be easy i just have
to stop the rook from getting in
let's put the knight on e6 maybe
maybe this move
hmm
this is really bad
um
the thing is if white can't break
through
like if the position closes down then
maybe there's some hope
very slim hope though
oh rookie six coming
probably gonna be zug
yeah this is this is not good
i guess i can take twice
i am controlling like all these squares
i'm just trying to resist for as long as
possible
oh white's triangulating oh that's
actually very clever
because i can't i can't triangulate
myself
and there goes my pawn try this
i'm looking for resources here play b6
yeah there's there's some easy wins for
white
king kim g4 is not one of them but
that's one
i'm looking for ways to be as tricky as
possible
yeah well played
i think the last one is don't get forked
i
underestimated the knight on f5
like i was safe here but it just didn't
register
your everyday life to remind you of
things etc
outside of streaming occasionally
i'll use it to set alarms or play music
or play podcasts
um
so kind of yeah
but it's not it's not too intrusive to
my life
oh as rosev actually don't know what
you're referring to
feel free to message me or whisper me
[Music]
um i mean you can always like yeah feel
free to do what you want though
um i don't mind
i know uh like this tournament i'm not
really looking too much at the chat
during the games budapest bits
it's a public thing i have no idea what
you're referring to
oh yeah was that the first wait did i
play the budapest yet
i don't think i've played the budapest
yet i've been trying
but everyone's avoiding it that's
berserk
maybe i'll allow my opponent to play
with the past
uh oh we're gonna have a queen's gambit
i don't usually play this
oh it's a stonewall
but this is not a great version of the
stonewall
i don't think split queen
queen c2 bishop d3 queenside castle
hmm yeah so the difference between the
knights is this is an outpost
this isn't an outpost but all the
knights might get traded anyway
it takes yeah i'll take here
play bishop d3 whoa it's vanguard with
our raid
wow thanks so much thanks vanguard
i don't think you've you've raided
before oh you you've been in the chat a
lot i really appreciate it
shout out to vanguard
i'm wondering were you streaming chess
or something else i know you play
another game
um really appreciate that
vanguard i spelled that correctly
if you're just joining this is chess
trying to figure out what to do oh i
okay
so if you're just joining i i started
this game
by giving time odds by basically cutting
my time in half
to try and get more tournament points
the position is nice
i want to break through eventually oh
among us oh that's what everyone's
streaming these days
which i've i've yet to do
okay let's play rookie two
yeah if you're just joining this is a
yearly blitz arena
it is a six hour long tournament
which i might i might play the rest of
i'm not sure yet
okay i want to go for g4
but not yet
[Music]
let's start with this defending the f
pawn so then after g4 takes takes
everything will be defended
try and build up the pressure
some weird tension here i like the rooks
what does it mean when it says daily
weekly accessory blitz arena
oh it refers to how often it happens
oh the structure is not good my time's
not good either
so i assume this this tournament happens
only once a year
weekly happens every week etc
at some point i'll do a poll of whether
i should play among us
and or fall guys
this is not good at all let's attack a
queen
i really gotta stay focused
ah i can move let's go for the
i'm in big trouble here
no i'm just getting made it oh but the
point misses it
i'm still getting mated don't know where
got one just wins
napoleon misses it again
now
ah i just flagged i was
really bad time management
i was actually so i was getting wrapped
up in like some stalemate ideas
because if i sack the the last
major pieces if i am able to sack both
rooks and the queen it's just stalemates
um so i wanted to take on g7 here
which like it that doesn't almost work
it's an idea like to take and then play
this
the problem is queen g6 and when i take
it's not stalemate
okay uh let's move on let's try and
fight through the downswing
i'll try and break back into the top 30.
it's been a lot of chess playing bubble
trouble
oh i have to bring back my reading too
okay neville
never played bubble trouble before
wait bubble trouble this used to be a
game
i used to play bubble trouble on
miniclip
i think bubble trouble falls for the
the main trap
would you rather never play chess again
or never leave your city again
oh i don't know
i kind of enjoy traveling
i'll prefer not to answer that question
that question just makes me sad
okay but this position makes me happy
yeah this bishop is dominant play h5
threatening this
i still want to play this oh opponent
wants to
do mean things i wonder if i can play
this first
there's also f6
i'll play f6 then there's e5
i could no i can't castle
okay f6 e5 bishop g4 bishop g4 queen e4
castle i think it's okay
some idea bishop c1 too
there's kind of a nifty move
i'm running out of coffee wait a minute
oh look at this bishop d2 king f2 bishop
g4
queen g3 bishop f4 traps the queen
okay that's nice this is what i was
going for
now today is not a t day
i needed more of a wake up to resort to
coffee
even though i had tea earlier i made a
big pot of green tea earlier
yeah white kind of realizing the doom
i win anything play this move
going after the pawn
yeah opening up the h file
g3 incoming
that was a nice game man bubble trouble
brings back memories i think that was a
mini clip
it's like an old game
now this game was more like double
trouble yeah
okay
so the leader has 100 only couple
players above a hundred
oh there's frogger too yeah
i haven't really played like these other
random games
at least recently oh i'm reminding you
turn on the fridge alexa remind me again
in two hours
okay i'll remind you again in two hours
thanks so much
appreciate it let's get some music
especially for the berserking game oh
what is this move
i've played against this in the past
why am i forgetting bishop d2 and then
e4
yeah this will be fun
hey it's korak okay it's music time
okay ready for it okay
i'll turn down the volume a little bit
okay just need some like extra energy
i was playing this earlier
i'm going to develop i want to go for a
d5 maybe
it's castle oh it takes i can take and
take
giving up the bishop hair but that's
okay i want to play bishop c3
[Music]
playing mr toot from istanbul
okay we can trade bishops it's like a
sicilian
dragon
i do like c3 maybe
[Music]
opponent perplexed ooh okay oh we could
treat queens
let's not trade queens because i want to
mate
knight g5 i'm gonna develop maybe knight
d5
play rookie one oh there's this move the
pin
it's also a rook b8 maybe b3
let's see 395 still on the horizon
let's play b3 first get this in
this is this an xc3
oh rook c8 this
maybe rexy one
[Music]
is it too loud oh maybe it's too loud
so sorry okay
okay going for the attack very huge time
advantage
[Music]
where are my ideas um
okay going for the kill
[Music]
oh
okay i got the triple fork or quadruple
four
that was nice that was really nice
and i'm up so much time
okay that's what i need a nice little
boost oh let's not get mated
that'd be really bad to like just
outplay the opponent and launder mate
uh let's play this move can you trade
queen's friend maiden one
attack a thing
oh g4 traps and knight
okay that was nice that's nice
i feel like i should play every game
this song
it like it gives me some boost gets me
gets me calculating
okay can i just loop this video oh i can
loop the video
nice
but do i do it though
will the song get old after a while i'm
not sure
oh shall i make it louder
i can't use it too much
okay i'll only use it in a time scramble
so when we both get below two minutes
i'll i'll play it how about
only in games where both berserk so it
doesn't get old and also it's faster
pace
yeah that's true okay i'm playing um a
funny line
pawn a3 we'll have kind of a scotch
type thing
uh play bishop e2 be solid
a slight space advantage white's
probably slightly better here
i think f4 is playable bishop f8 bishop
f3
yeah bishop c6 is fine for black play
queen d3 defend the pawn
rook wants to come to e1
so an eventual idea of e5 maybe
wondering if b4 is playable might as
well throw it in
oh do i play baby shark
i feel like that's just a big no-no
it's one way to get a lot of haters
maybe
isn't baby shark like the most played
song on youtube
i'm pretty sure the the numbers for that
like the viewership for
for that is just insane
okay let's focus to do
maybe the knight can come to f2 pawn can
come to c4
just going for the slow squeeze
bishop here i have c4
oh i have this idea too
i should have considered a move sooner
but maybe it's still working
because there's no 98 there's no knight
h5 there's queen e6
or rookie six
and it's getting confusing now
so if i play f5
takes takes takes takes
i lose f oh the bishop is on leash two
but we just trade everything
maybe c5 is the way to go
ah it's really confusing
i'm not moving quickly enough
uh
i don't know what to do
let's play let's play this and hope for
the best
um this isn't good
okay let's take okay let's play the song
this will get me to move quicker
ah i'm so low on time but i have e5
maybe okay things are happening
bishop's attacked oh but the thing is
pinned so we could trade
maybe 94 coming attacking stuff
g4 maybe f5
uh i don't know about that let's attack
a queen
queen d5 i win the queen
okay trying to break through attacking a
rook and the pawn
takes takes queen f7 in the end
oh i missed knight f6 oh but the rook's
attacked
us you are the best oh i threw you too
thank you i'm singer what's up i'm
singer
[Music]
hey i won okay we don't even reach the
the climax of the song
thinks i'm singer
okay the so i i felt like i was
slightly in trouble already thank you so
much for the great content
the song works the song really works oh
thank you so much
oh dino appreciate that
okay oh okay let's preserve again
um do i play a walrus
and saturn thanks for subbing playing on
walrus
okay so i have a pawn in e4 and d3 may
be expected
let's reinforce the pawn
yeah preventing bishop g5 it's only like
decent square for the bishop
knight d2 is a good move let's take
bishop e7
queen queen d7 queen e2 bishop here
could castle either way oh 95 coming
confusing position
maybe castle kingside then 95 maybe
queen d4
okay let's put the rook on the open file
maybe bishop can come to c5
i like coming to g4 potentially oh i'm
also maybe threatening
some tactics never mind
okay let's attack the queen that
probably only helped white
okay bishop f8
okay
so some knight d5 idea actually knight
d5 followed by bishop b4
is a main idea
yeah this is a secret threat
which opponent kind of deals with
oh it's getting spicy i'm gonna take and
then play bishop b4 anyway
so i'm stacking exchange but probably
winning the exchange back
oh the bishop control c3
that's not good
i just lost 16. the spiciest thing about
you
oh when i order
[Music]
spicy thai food
or just my stafford gambit probably
okay c3 induced
we're trading rooks
okay i need the song the song will save
me hopefully
okay let's do this i'm down in exchange
not the best position
but we're going to try and fight
let's see five coming oh i have a no a5
doesn't quite work though
how many staffords already today so many
so many okay c5 i take that's a good
move
of c5 anyway this move
ah this is a difficult position my time
is very difficult but i'm threatening
bishop e5
[Music]
this move don't hurt me
don't hurt me
okay knight of three i'm too happy it
doesn't work though
the song's not working i'm getting
smashed
ah no
[Music]
oh okay maybe i defend everything
ah okay let's attack the pawn
i have 18 seconds no
this is really bad oh
but what's giving me hope giving me lots
of hope
rook is kind of trapped with b7 i taken
c6
c4 coming let's go b5
abominus b4 coming
so fine let's go
come back
[Music]
no my hope
no
[Music]
don't hurt me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
was unfortunate i was coming back too
i was coming back so well
look at these ponds i won the bishop
this pond was dangerous so this pond was
so dangerous
man is this in the hall of the mountain
king
i knew i loved you yes yes someone
recommended it earlier
and now i've discovered it makes me play
much better
and especially like okay this game like
i was just losing and then
the song didn't seem to be working but
then it started working
okay i'll try not to overkill it
we'll have some silent games maybe
or maybe we can try some new songs
okay i have an idea i'm gonna play rook
e4
so defending the pawn if it takes and i
play g4 and then i'll win this
okay so i think we're oh
oh wow what a move
it just that just wins does it
oh that's so sad
look at that move
that's really sad yeah like here i can't
play d5 because it takes
okay so i'll try and fight
four pawns versus three
thanks for subbing cody mitch something
g
um yeah this is pretty bad though
let's try this and bring the king in
down on time i mean the goal is to trade
off all the pawns and then try and hold
a draw
and the question is do i play the other
song the song that has saved me a few
times
i think i should it's my only hope
okay let's do this i'm down at night
and down on time but
i have hope i have a nice pawn chain
i have an active rook i don't know what
the oh the knight wants to destroy me
[Music]
uh-oh wants to literally
just check maybe
i don't know how to deal with this i
guess i have to go for counter play
king e6 d5 d6
um that's gonna be annoying maybe this
one keep rook b7
there's some stalemate ideas too if i
lose the pawn
yeah so here and here but then 96
uh oh don't hurt me
okay that's what i like to see some
mercy
let's push the pawn if here i perpetual
it's getting tricky if f5 i play rookie
7
aha there's no knight g6 so i take it
[Music]
tristan do this
maybe i don't know what's going on here
but i'm fighting fighting perpetual
good move
[Music]
i mean it's not bad
how bad is this
[Music]
it's really bad
[Music]
no ah i'm losing
ah that was unfortunate oh i'm so close
though
i was so close oh sorry if it was loud
okay
it didn't work it was close like i i
kind of fought back
it's so unfortunate though like after
rook g5
um black is forcing a rook trade
like there's no way for me to preserve
the rook
i wanted to like move all the way of a
check and then rook g7
um and there's really nothing else to do
i was looking for stalemate traps too of
course
maybe i should have i don't know what i
should have done left the tension
somehow work here
difficult position though
yeah maybe king f7 slightly better try
but
okay let's play one more let's play one
more
i'm running slightly low on energy
despite all the coffee
yeah sorry sorry if it was too loud um
okay one more game no berserking no
music this scene
can we get one with the past please wow
everyone playing knight f3
no one wants to run into the budapest
oh this is like a weird catalan move
order
so yeah the approach is to play knight
c6 and go into this line
i'll admit i'm not so booked up here
i think i can take on i take on d4
or create at some point
yeah i know there's some people who like
the music some people that don't like
the music
so um
in general this is my go-to
piece of advice if you like the music
open a new tab
and you can listen to it on loop
also fun fact with youtube with any
youtube video you can just right click
on the video and select loop and it'll
loop any video
it's great for music
i could do a poll too but it's too much
work
erin gold thanks for subbing with prime
oh if you're on phone yeah then maybe
it's trickier
um let's play this
so i'm giving white the option of taking
and then
white would get two rooks for a queen
but then it would be interesting
maybe i have e4 in the end of that line
okay so light wins a pawn
so it's equal material rook's attacked
oh bishop's attack too ooh so i guess i
have to play
i have to play rookie eight
i'm losing this pawn
and or this pawn wow i didn't even see
that
yeah i'm it's definitely a sign that i'm
running low on focus
let's play bishop here
fight a little bit trying to take a mini
two also maybe threatening some
sort of discovery okay the queen's a
little bit awkward
play queen g6 so now i'm throwing this
but no longer attacking e2
so it's interesting of rook p8
there's some compensation
of a52 play a5
and then this
so i'm trying to chase the queen away
yeah so now
i have access to h5
i can take play queen h5 of king h2 i
have knight g4
that's probably the way to go
it's not easy for white to like
comfortably defend
the h3 pawn
allen l would you rather be the best
chess player in the world or be able to
teleport anywhere
once per day once per oh
definitely teleportation
i feel like there'd be so many more
opportunities
if i could teleport be so nice
that's a happier question i forget which
question was asked earlier
okay wait let's focus down a minute
g4 is actually a good move i want a sack
but it doesn't quite work
queen e5 runs into bishop d4
queen h4
[Music]
bishop f4 is coming
actually okay let's play this bishop d4
at least i can win back upon
[Music]
maybe endure the bad structure actually
bishop d4 queen
queen e2 bishop f6 gf6 queen a5
and still try and fight
if i get a chance i want to play h5
even knight d5
like the king side's a little bit loose
for white
safe move
play rook b2 and try and be as
active as possible
okay now
let's take
and it's not looking pretty
okay the good thing is okay
i have to focus on the game
if takes takes on not getting mated king
is relatively safe
queen should not be getting trapped
now actually if takes i made in two
one of the plans is to sack the rook
queen a5 might be coming
yeah a good move so maybe this move
but then g5
what else to do maybe h6 just creating
some luft
some idea of maneuvering the knight
if i'm down the pawn that's probably a
good move
i'm not sure if there's a threat play
rook a2 attack
the pawn
i'm wondering if i can at some point
play queen g5 trade queens try and win
the pawn
the annoying thing is i don't really
have rookies the bishop's always here
okay
so now white has a threat
knight d5 doesn't work
i have to play queen g6
and what else to do let's play queen g6
hanging on time is getting low for both
of us
yeah rook beats off limits unfortunately
trying to calculate bishop d5 doesn't
work here
put the rook on e8 f4 i can move back to
c2
that's scary
this move
really want to take on g4
yolo let's do it
there's a lot of stuff happening here
because now i attack the bishop and the
rook and threatening discover checks
i am temporarily down a piece but maybe
it doesn't matter so much
oh there's a funny line bishop g2 bishop
f3 queen g3 i take and then i
the the rook helps out
that's a move
that's a good move
i have to go for this not what i want
finding this now
it takes i have rook c1 roxy one coming
anyway
okay
down on time but maybe it doesn't matter
let's go
g5 let's go
okay wow what a game
somehow i survived it was like the end
the um there's a famous scene from
searching for body fisher where both
sides promote and then there's like a
queen skewer in the end
it's kind of reminiscent
okay yeah i was much
worse queen g3 was a good move white's
clearly better here but then
fell for this trick probably should have
moved the rook over
okay i was down on time too
i was lucky i was able to pre-move like
most of the end game
oh yeah yeah this uh this ending doesn't
call for a hand sanitizer
this is relatively clean at least
towards the end
middle game was a bit messy though yeah
it was just carelessly blundering
i mean it's kind of the nature of the
opening these pawns are weak
hey g5 was crucial
had to go for the the extra queen or the
two extra queens
actually curious just the theory here
oh queen a4 is not a move ah yeah main
line is to take
so queen a4
okay apparently rook be it is better uh
some idea of rook b4
okay well
it's been a lot of chess i wasn't sure
if i was gonna make it through the whole
tournament
i don't think i will be playing the
whole tournament
um but had some fun games
i do appreciate people watching and
cheering akd7
not to post this whole stream on youtube
um that's a good point
i've posted the previous two years of
the yearly blitz arena so i should
probably post this whole thing i just
have to check
for the the music copyrights youtube
usually runs the algorithm
so hopefully it's okay so
if this thing goes or just if this whole
thing goes on youtube
i hope you guys enjoy that youtube
audience comment below if you watch the
whole thing
usually when i upload
streams lasting more than two hours
only five to ten percent of viewers
actually watch the whole thing on
youtube
um but that's okay there's a lot of a
lot of fun games in this
uh this tournament uh thanks again to
everyone
for the supports everyone cheering and
subbing
and following and chatting